all right here's what everyone knows
about chocolate milk chocolate tastes
the best dark chocolate is okay orange
chocolate is disgusting m m's don't need
anything in them they're fine how they
are and chocolate covered pretzels are
far and away better than chocolate
covered strawberries now here's what
everyone doesn't know about chocolate
chocolate contains several different
compounds that cause the same effects on
the body as coffee marijuana and
amphetamines this is because the plant
that chocolate is extracted from the
cocoa plant or theobroma cacao is a
tropical plant some tropical plants
evolve to produce compounds called
alkaloids either for self-defense or
competition alkaloids are organic
compounds that contain one or more
nitrogen atoms and some have
pharmacological effects on the human
body
the most known and benign alkaloid in
chocolate is caffeine but this isn't a
big deal because caffeine is found in
nearly everything we drink soda coffee
and tea everybody drinks it and you know
what everyone else does too surf the
internet unprotected but you can be
different by using nordvpn right now
your isp is logging your browsing
activity they can see all the different
kinds of chocolate you're searching for
after watching this video afterwards
they can sell that data to advertisers
who then post chocolate ads everywhere
you browse chocolate chocolate chocolate
chocolate chocolate chocolate chocolate
keep your chocolate search history
private by using nordvpn nord not only
keeps you safe from hackers by
concealing your ip address through
remote servers but also encrypts your
data so it can't be logged sure you
could use free vpns but at a cost slower
connection speeds and higher traffic
also those free vpns aren't really free
they have to make a profit too some
actually log your browsing history and
then sell it to advertisers for profit
and then this happens
however nord is a paid for vpn service
so you pay for faster speeds and nord
has a strict no logging user activity
policy so your browsing is truly private
nordvpn is offering 73 off a two-year
plan plus four additional months for
free for only three dollars and eighteen
cents per month check the description
for more details
the way caffeine works in making you
awake is by blocking adenosine receptors
in your nervous system normally when
adenosine binds to the adenosine
receptors it inhibits neuronal activity
making neurons fire at a slower speed
thus making you feel tired when you
drink coffee tea or soda or eat
chocolate caffeine binds to the
adenosine receptors blocking adenosine
altogether thereby preventing you from
feeling tired making you feel awake and
alert but here's the thing chocolate
only has trace amounts of caffeine about
0.24
by weight so one ounce of dark chocolate
would only have about 12 milligrams of
caffeine less than half a cup of green
tea the predominant stimulant in
chocolate is not caffeine but rather is
theobromine yeah i know they look nearly
identical especially if you don't study
chemistry but there is a difference i
can assure you for example there is a
hydrogen atom bound to this nitrogen
atom on theobromine right here whereas
caffeine there is no hydrogen atom bound
there at all and this does matter
theobromine is an alkaloid and is also a
stimulant causing a feeling of
wakefulness by blocking the same
receptors as caffeine oh and it's also
the substance that makes chocolate toxic
to dogs due to very high concentrations
on average there's about 300 milligrams
of theobromine per 1 ounce of chocolate
25 times more than caffeine compared to
caffeine theobromine is a mild stimulant
it's slower acting and has a longer
duration whereas caffeine is fast acting
and has a much shorter duration despite
there being a lot of theobromine and
chocolate it doesn't make you jittery
and hyper but can chocolate make you
jittery and hyper yes if you eat enough
of it but there's not enough caffeine in
it and theobromine is just a mild
stimulant so what does it
our third alkaloid phenylethylamine this
is phenylethylamine and this is
amphetamine they're very very similar in
structure and this is a big deal
amphetamine is very similar in structure
to methamphetamine or more simply meth
which as you know from watching breaking
bad is a very strong nervous system
stimulant by nature this makes
amphetamine a nervous system stimulant
as well though not as strong as
methamphetamine and by nature of
similarity and structure makes
phenylethylamine a nervous system
stimulant as well which again
is in chocolate the same stuff that your
kids eat at halloween and easter in fact
phenylethylamine activates the exact
same receptors in the nervous system as
amphetamine causing the release of
dopamine and norepinephrine in the body
the release of dopamine gives you a
feeling of happiness while
norepinephrine makes you feel jittery
and aware by increasing heart rate in
raising blood sugar levels but chocolate
is not exclusively a stimulant like
cocaine aside from these alkaloids
there's also cannabinoids in chocolate
the same compounds found in marijuana
the most significant being anatomide
anatomide binds to the same cb1 and cb2
receptors as thc and induces a similar
high effect on the brain making you feel
relaxed and blissful though anatomide
binds to the same receptors as thc and
does induce a very similar effect its
effects are only slightly potent this is
because the body makes a very small
amount of its own anatomies and recycles
it using the enzyme fatty acid amide
hydrolase or faah for short which breaks
down anatomide into arachidonic acid and
ethanolamine disabling its activity
thereby making any high effects of
external anatomic use very short-lived
so you can't really get high by eating
chocolate but you can feel relaxed and
blissful thc on the other hand lasts
much longer in the body so its effects
are longer lasting and more noticeable
now all chocolate contains these
different compounds but the caveat is
not all chocolate has the same amount
the more concentrated the chocolate the
more alkaloids and cannabinoids it has
the question is which chocolate is the
most concentrated and thereby has the
most compounds well let's see first up
is white chocolate well this isn't even
really chocolate moving on second is
milk chocolate ah yes the chocolate
that's literally in everything we eat
hershey's bars reese's m ms snickers
kitkats even the salad chocolate you eat
at easter yes milk chocolate is mostly
not chocolate
that's right you heard me it's not
chocolate okay you've been lied to the
moon landing was fake water isn't really
blue the earth is flat oswald was the
lone shooter the walking dead should end
it at season ten okay your life is a lie
okay maybe i'm getting a little far
ahead of myself here but seriously milk
chocolate is only about 12 real
chocolate or cocoa mass by weight here's
a visual of the amount of ingredients in
a real 1.5 ounce milk chocolate bar this
little bit here is the chocolate that's
added to it the other 88
in order of amount is forty eight point
six percent sugar twenty percent milk
salads nineteen percent butter and zero
point four percent less of thin and
flavoring when you eat milk chocolate
you're essentially eating a mixture of
sugar milk and butter which is why you
hardly feel the effects of these
compounds
on the other hand dark chocolate is much
different it's on average 60 percent
real chocolate with the remaining
difference being sugar lecithin and
flavoring however it can go up to
concentrations as high as 85 sometimes
90
and by far has substantially higher
concentrations of these compounds for
example a 50 gram milk chocolate candy
bar only contains about 9 milligrams of
caffeine and 56 milligrams of
theobromine very small quantities in
contrast a 50 gram ecuadorian dark
chocolate bar at 75 cacao contains 75
milligrams of caffeine and 426
milligrams of theobromine the dark
chocolate bar has an equivalent of three
quarters of a cup of coffee and seven
times the amount of theobromine wow not
to mention higher levels of
phenylethylamine and anatomide but the
highest concentration of chocolate that
you can find that's edible is baking
chocolate which is 100
pure cocoa mass so if after the video
you want to experience the effects of
chocolate that's the best way to go but
be forewarned it tastes terrible there's
no sugar butter or milk in it so it's
very bitter oh and don't worry about
overdosing it's nearly impossible the
most toxic and substantial alkaloid in
chocolate is theobromine and if you eat
enough of it it can kill you but the
question is how much is lethal well for
a 165 pound person they would have to
ingest over 75 000 milligrams of
theobromine or 250 pounds of chocolate
so you'll likely either throw up or be
in a diabetic coma before you die in
conclusion chocolate has a range of
stimulants and cannabinoids that are
also found in coffee marijuana and
amphetamines the overall effect of these
compounds depending on how much you
consume result in wakefulness feeling
alert and happy or content the higher
the concentration of chocolate or cocoa
mass the more stimulants and
cannabinoids you consume milk chocolate
has trace amounts dark chocolate has
substantially more and baking chocolate
has the most so yeah
that's the video thanks for watching
you